à l'école et je perdais tous mes moyens
d'une timidité radical maladive
c'est bien simple je rougis c'est à tout
bout de champ ça n'arrangeait pas mes
affaires parce que j'avais envie de
faire l'intéressant avec les filles
et puis avec mes camarades jamais leur
compagnie j'aimais avoir de l' influence
sur eux un professeur m'avait démasqué
il avait accueilli ainsi ma mère à
l'occasion d'un débat à l'école ils
rouge voulez parler de mes opinions
politiques
et que quand ils m'interroger je perdais
tous mes moyens
en partant il avait dit dans la classe
c'est lui qui commande
bon là il exagérait un peu j'avais 15
ans mais j'étais fier quand même parce
que je voyais le monde comme étant trop
vaste et trop compliqué et je peinais à
trouver ma place
bref pour devenir quelqu'un
il fallait que ça change alors comme
j'avais du mal à soutenir un regard j'ai
trouvé le truc de me brouiller les yeux
voilà j'étais devant mon interlocuteur
sans le regarder
et puis tout d'un coup eh bien je
devenais un cador
infor quelqu'un qui savait s'imposer bon
tout ça ne durera qu'un temps et finit
par des dégâts dalmau logique c'est
l'art qui m'a permis de vaincre ma
timidité
enfin l'art
rock musique je me souviens de ma
première prestation je chantais dans un
groupe devant le réfectoire du lycée et
là je m'étais rouler par terre et
j'avais composé moi même les paroles
cette année car et année car est un
héros des soultes en latin les chaînes
sont brisées bon ça a été un choc
merveilleux mon mon premier choc et
adrénaline
alors passons passons sur ma carrière de
rocker qui est resté sans lendemain
j'ai vécu un deuxième shoot avec le
théâtre j'étais à la fac et un copain
est venu me recruter pour le rôle de tri
g dans la paix d'aristophane il avait
une défection et en quelques semaines
j'ai dû apprendre le métier placer ma
voix me déplacer sur la scène à prendre
des milliers de vers comment on fait
pour apprendre des milliers de vers le
metteur en scène est venu à mon secours
il m'a dit c'est moins compliqué qu'on
croit il faut relier les paroles à
l'espace
alors quand tu fais tel geste passé pour
dire telle chose et quand tu te déplaces
ici ou là c'est pour jouer ou jouer
telle ou telle situation
et puis si tu te souviens de rien tu
inventes le soir de la première
sap a été terrible j'ai dû inventer la
moitié du texte mais peu importe
j'avais vécu une des désirs deuxième
choc merveilleux un deuxième shoot
d'adrénaline
j'avais un masque énorme qui me
descendait jusqu'à la taille
formidable manuel tout war élèves et les
grands et toi vin coûte activités en
souvenir de cette histoire parce que
depuis je suis devenu directeur de
théâtre je suis devenu metteur en scène
j'ai fondé le théâtre vollard de la
réunion et bien j'essaie de donner leur
chance aux débutants moi j'aime ceux qui
sont courageux ceux qui sont téméraires
pas besoin de diplôme
j'aime ce qui faut vite et bien
et là j'ai deux noms qu'il vienne à
l'esprit celui de jean luc trulès à qui
on peut tout demander en musique et
celui et celui d'hervé bazin qui on peut
tout demander en scénographie
le premier n'a pas fait le conservateur
des compositeurs et le deuxième a
commencé au tri à la poste sans parler
d' arnaud dormeuil notre vedette au
départ
au départ apprenti maçon pratiquer le
théâtre dans un dom tom n'est pas chose
facile
nous avons eu beaucoup de succès nous
avons eu des milliers de spectateurs
nous avons créé 30 spectacle nous avons
joué à l'étranger nous avons eu des
critiques dans le journal le monde le
point l'express libe nous avons traité
librement de tous les sujets qui fâchent
à la réunion la politique les religions
la sorcellerie
les élections ne puissent les migrations
lesques la page nous avons été expulsé
quatre fois nous avons été ruinée cent
fois nous avons fait la grève de la faim
nous avons manifesté dans la rue nous
avons protesté dans les journaux nous
avons combattu l'extrême droite à
l'extrême gauche
les cuvées lit les nervis l'état les
flics les juges
voilà qui nous amène à mon troisième
shoot l'opéra
ça c'est ma petite lunette j'emporte
avec moi quand je vais au spectacle
comme ça je peux voir la chanteuse
les chanteurs les choristes
le chef d'orchestre
j'avais deux procès sur le dos le
premier en correctionnelle pour injure
l'administration le deuxième au tribunal
de grande instance pour la liquidation
judiciaire de ma compagnie et là je me
suis dit c'est fini pour nous le théâtre
alors on a essayé de faire de la musique
on a créé un groupe on organisait des
concerts on a enregistré décédé et puis
pas de chance on est tombé sur la crise
du pire du piratage sur internet
j'ai fait du cinéma j'ai travaillé avec
yves boisset j'ai joué avec charles
berling rupert everett mimie mathy et là
je me suis dit pourquoi pas l'opéra
c'est du théâtre santé on travaillera
avec d'autres artistes
on aura affaire à une autre
administration on respirera un autre air
avec jean-luc on est retourné à l'école
lui pour écrire des partitions grosse
comme ça et dirigé d'immenses orchestre
mois pour écrire des livres est et pour
recruter des chanteuses et des chanteurs
ont crié au fou ah oui on est terminée
et l'opéra c'est cher avec un immense
orchestre avec avec des décors avec des
coeurs qui viennent de madagascar avec
du champagne à l'entracte on à
redémarrer à zéro on a réappris à être
petit humble et puis surtout j'ai connu
des émotions artistiques nouvelles
je pensais être blindé de ce côté là et
je me suis surpris à voilà larmes aux
yeux quand la soliste elle est seule sur
scène et que leur caisse fait monter la
sauce
derrière quand on pleure on est vivants
alors avec voilà on a écrit et produit
deux opéras madame chine est le
troisième freedom est en route
si on nous avait pas interdit théâtre on
n'aurait jamais fait l'opéra
qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir de tout ça
eh ben n'allez pas là où on vous dit
d'aller suivez votre voix là haut il
faut frêle rarement du bien alors battez
vous défendez vous celui qui se bat et
gagne toujours quelque chose et surtout
rester debout
non